former chief of the general staff
general lord danette joins me now
and certainly this was the
commander-in-chief of all armed
personnel who swore an oath of
allegiance to her what will their loss
be felt today
well um
the loss is very real and is very great
i think as we all woke up this morning
we had that sort of sinking realization
in our hearts that the day that we had
dreaded that the queen would die was
yesterday and today is the new day it's
beginning of something else and you're
absolutely right for members of the
armed forces the royal navy the british
army of the royal air force
it's particularly special it's also very
personal because on the day that we join
one of the three armed forces we swear
an oath of allegiance and not to the
government um not to the minister of
state for defense or anything like that
but actually to the sovereign
and 28th of august 1969 when i held a
bible in my hand i swore an oath of
allegiance to
the queen queen elizabeth ii but that
allegiance as she breathed her last
breath
passed seamlessly
to the new king to king charles iii and
that's who our allegiance is with now
and you know
it's an incredible aspect part of the
unbritten british constitution for those
of us who choose to serve the nation in
uniform
we serve the nation we serve the person
of the sovereign and that's a very
special aspect and um that allegiance
has now passed uh just in a flash of
lightning as it were from queen
elizabeth ii to king charles iii that's
very very special and this is now the
start of something new just as we look
back with great fondness and all our
memories of just how special that person
of queen elizabeth ii was
and of course this is a family that's
that's steeped in military history
itself is it not you know prince philip
committed to the navy a job that he had
to give up to marry the queen prince
andrew
served in the falklands princess william
and harry to harry in afghanistan you
know it really was all around them are
the queen's own children and
grandchildren being part of this service
well that's absolutely right um
the sovereign and the members of the
royal family take their very close
association with
the royal navy the british army the
royal air force very very seriously and
and it's really important that they do
and they do it very willingly and they
do it extraordinarily well because
it's the embodiment of that personal
link between every individual service
man and service woman with
the head of state with the sovereign and
that link is is so very very special so
as i said just a moment or two ago
this is a great loss for the nation but
actually it's a very personal loss for
soldiers sailors airmen and women and
marines um because the the sovereign
is our our leader is our
commander-in-chief um
and that
commander-in-chief role passed
seamlessly yesterday from queen
elizabeth ii to king charles iii it's
very special it's very personal i think
it's almost unique in the world
other countries like the united states
and france
the elected politician who is the head
of state um
is there a
senior person but in this country there
is something mystical there's something
magical there's something spiritual
there's something very special about
having the sovereign as the head of
state and the head of our armed forces
um
i think it's unique it's certainly very
very special
well we hear you certainly law richard
dannett former chief of the general
staff thank you
thank you